[Applause]
hey everyone how's it going there's a
star war coming a han Solo I'm ash
Carlson joined by mike rizzo from
GameSpot thanks for being here fresh off
the Philly win the Eagles want the Super
Bowl anyways so if you did watch the
Super Bowl you saw that 45 second Han
Solo teaser with the trailer dropping
this morning Good Morning America and we
have not watched it yet I didn't want to
get up early anyway yeah well me neither
but last night celebrating celebrating
the Eagles win anyways um so yeah we
haven't watch the trailer yet so we're
gonna watch it right now for the first
time and react to it this movie comes
out in like over eight and a half months
and we're just now getting the first
very close very close
I personally am alarmed well let's do it
let's watch it so long a Star Wars story
I've been running scams on the streets
since I was 10
scoundrel just kick that ass light
Academy kicked out of the flight Academy
for having a mind in my own school sucks
I'm gonna be a pilot [ __ ] him
I don't know they all have fur coat oh
wow fur coat nation I'm putting together
a crew
what up Woody um oh you win that's yes
so he's known Chewbacca we're gonna have
a favorite droid I might be Bo any
person Millie looks good she does oh
[Music]
really uh
she's like the main character of this
trailer what so who they're gonna kiss
what are you just saying no no
[Applause]
[Music]
now we're in trouble there for a second
but it's fine we're fine what there's
always a bigger thing Memorial Day
that's really different from that's
really different from the Super Bowl
spot
yeah well the Super Bowl spot like
showed just like one glimpse of his face
right yeah but then it has like yeah the
end and it was like there's like hype
yeah because he was barely in that one
where Han Solo looks like but because
you forgot but that one like I feel like
the Super Bowl spot was like I screamed
over like the Lando and then the the
hand on the shoulder thing that wasn't
even that wasn't even in that can we can
we see that part again with where he
said he had won his one-liner at the end
yeah what's that I'm on set I don't know
if that trailer make you more excited
for the Han Solo movie that's a question
like how did you feel before and how do
you feel after watching the trailer
worried I don't trust Star Wars
marketing anymore because of rogue one
yes completely false trailer right like
that trailer had nothing to do with what
that movie was and regardless of what
you think of rogue one like the trailer
was not a good indication of what that
movie was gonna be and I feel like this
could very much turn out given that like
there was there's been similar like
production problems throughout the
build-up to this movie and the fact that
we're getting this trailer three months
before the movies out that is really
wild to me like I get they wanted to
leave the space for between the last
Jedi and the space
Wow I guess I wanted to like force space
between the last Jedi and starting to
promote solo but I still feel like it's
wildly close to the movie I don't know I
also feel like because it was a Lord and
Miller movie and then Ron Howard took it
over and I get that I still feel like I
was expecting like this kind of
light-hearted comedy vibe and it's it
seems like very like dark gritty Star
Wars you
you go back in like the reports that
were coming out like when word Miller
were out and they were looking for
another director was like Lord Miller
thought they were making a comedy mm-hmm
and Lucasfilm just wanted them to like
add a comedic touch yeah where's like
like if you look at last Jedi like it
doesn't feel like a Rian Johnson movie
it feels like a Star Wars movie with a
little bit of a Rian Johnson right and I
feel like they wanted the same from Lord
Miller so I'm not surprised that this
doesn't seem like a very funny movie
like it could turn out to be I'm sure
there's gonna be like good jokes that
we're all gonna like all Star Wars this
is comedy in it but it's not like a
comedy I'm not I mean this is basically
that especially from reading those
reports about like they wanted it to be
more serious and just have a touch of
comedy yeah that is kind of the tone
that I was expecting so that's to me
that's not surprising yeah well okay so
they they did release some character
posters as well and I believe some
images bring take a look that we're
gonna take a look at sweets so in the
teaser that they show during the
Superbowl Lando had that John snow look
going on Ted that big black fur coat
yeah looking dope ah see perhaps a hot
take I'm not really sure like my feeling
on it is and I've said this a million
times I didn't I'm not like super hyper
on solo movie because I don't feel like
there's anything about Han Solo's
backstory that I need filled in right
there's nothing mysterious chondral and
a rogue yeah like we get it he is an
archetype and and Harrison Ford is an
archetypal actor to be playing him and
like he works for that reason like I
don't need to know more about Han Solo
that's why I thought I liked the mystery
of like did he lie to get onto the
mission to older I'm like I like I like
to kind of imagining my own backstory
there but when you saw that shot of
window I'm like I would have liked oh
lambda yeah oh my god a land character
that's completely like shrouded in
mystery aside from what like the guy
that we met yes I can't wait for
somebody to recut this one sit out as a
land of movie
oh I'm sure somebody already has because
I've seen a boy I saw like so many
tweets even last night with the Super
Bowl spot where people are just like
Lando a Star Wars story would have been
dope it's so much better
really interesting in this because he's
liked - like you know sexy guy and he's
look at that smile this pristine
Millennium Falcon like what it Han Solo
due to the Millennium phone right yeah
he junked it what happened what happened
that could have been so bad that it made
the walls it was so it was pristine see
so you do have questions about handsome
yeah well that's the only thing I hope
the whole movie is just like what he did
to the Falcon I don't understand just
him just him junk in the thing in Lander
going oh come on man
oh you know he's gonna see that Falcon
about happen yeah I mean that said I'm
I'm open to this movie like it could
obviously it could be yeah it could be
amazing we could all be eating our words
sure I mean we're prejudging you know
comes with being on the internet it's
called healthy skepticism the trailer
looks good it does it does we have not
seen Tandy yeah also wearing four big
first centric movie here's like the do
you think it's cold all the time or they
just big Game of Thrones fans
you're gonna light up the combat
we got woody woody with the with he kind
of reminds me of Galen torso from rogue
one in this uh-huh kind of got that by
except he's in the snow do you like his
hair yeah I feel like that's the main
thing to focus on here because I think I
think I like it so he's playing Han
Solo's like like mentor gowns were like
teaching him how to be like a good
criminal or whatever I don't know maybe
yeah maybe like Han Solo is such an
unorganized criminal like you got kicked
out of the flight academy got kicked out
of the plant even and he's like listen
if you're gonna be a scoundrel you're
gonna be a good so you're gonna do it
right you're gonna do it right you're
gonna get kicked out of school and
you're gonna own it you're gonna like
smuggle stuff for the Empire get a lot
of money out of this
that's what is that what's happening I
don't know find out it seemed like in a
Super Bowl spot he was like I hope not
the Empire yeah oh yeah there was a lot
more Empire in that than there wasn't
this yeah this was just like it's I
assumed that this would be a longer
version of that like kind of different
like almost two different trailers and
teasers cool stuff whatever
see this is cool this makes me think
it's gonna be have like a Western yeah I
do like that definitely like
Steve I see but that's but like this
this shot here is like oh maybe there's
a Western you know what I mean yeah that
might not even be in the movie this is
why I don't trust trailers like we don't
know if it's gonna have a Western vibe I
hope it has a Western vibe that's cool
yeah like have we had a Star Wars movie
or like a real West like rogue one was
like the war movie yeah they're all a
little bit like that yeah baby slightly
lean into it so this is this is like
what kind of gave me the indication that
the vibe would be a little different
because it's like very like bright
colorful and like I thought I'd be like
this bright colorful kind of I don't
know why I thought it was gonna be like
this weird 90s look but that's what I
like I guess cause maybe because of
Amelia collects bangs Keira with a Q
yeah with an apostrophe you know I
apostrophe RA
Clara I don't know I thought it was
gonna have this like weird right 90s
vibe for some reason in the trailers a
lot dark in the trailers pretty dark but
those I mean those posters are a lot of
fun and I don't know I feel like I
already know more about like Emilia
Clarke like Keira I mean I already know
more about her than I knew about like
any of the characters in force awakens
leading up to that like grey orphan it
was like I knew that actor who played
them but like we're already seeing more
of Karen I kind of enjoy with the with
the story movies with the Thames between
ones that they can play a little more
like fast and loose with the marketing
and sort of tease it in a more effective
way right yeah they don't have to play
the the secret game right which I'm very
over although it really is it's really
crazy leaving it to the last minute any
final thoughts not so low a Star Wars
story yeah do you think he looks like
Han Solo here's the thing I um love all
the nerd drink and I love him as Han
Solo because we were at Star Wars
Celebration Europe and they brought him
out on stage and he like comes out and
he's just like weaving and talking about
stepping onto the Falcon for the first
time he he says Falcon which is like
hell
that's how Han says it the first time so
it just really stuck with me I was like
I feel like I'm watching han solo
onstage like his mannerisms were like
very charming and the way he was talking
I was like this is hot like you do think
he's like in character at that point I
was like I clean it up a little bit
maybe that's cool boy that's cool but
you that's an experience that you have
that like most people yeah I feel like
they're not doing a great job of like
highlighting him because I think there
may be a little afraid of that well not
nothing that he did in this trailer made
me think oh there you know what I mean
you're waiting for that moment where
it's like he's like he is han Solo right
and I'm we didn't get I feel like they
kind of needed to have that moment right
I don't think they did one thing I am
happy about though is that so in that
image that they are initially released
with Lord Miller and they had like our
first look at all the characters like
Han Solo's hair was I gotta wet and
they're really glad that it's you know
it's nice and quaffed and flowing and
well maybe that's not maybe that'll be
part of what woody teaches them because
Woody's hair is so great about he'll be
like no you gotta get the good pomade
right you gotta you gotta look the part
the first thing he says he's like hi
what product are you using because I'm
glad about that so I asked you the
question that you asked me first which
is are you now more excited about this
movie less excited or equally neutral um
I think it kind of helped get rid of
like some reservations that this movie
is a total disastrous mess because we
like weren't seeing anything for someone
not even a still without Lord and Miller
so right I was just kind of like what is
the vibe of this movie gonna be like is
it just gonna be this total like clump
together disaster yeah so now we can see
that like there it is a film it is a
film that exists there are shot
definitely doesn't seem like they're
pushing it back to December other people
think they're gonna do um I'll uh I
think I like what I see I mean I'm
definitely good like it's not like I'm
like not seeing this movie no I'm really
excited for it I don't feel like any
more like wow like I can't wait to see
the story because there's something in
there that's like really grabbing me but
I'm into it yeah I'm looking forward to
it just because I I'm always looking
forward to something different in the
Star Wars universe me other I mean like
the last Jedi whatever but they often
play it pretty safe like I even thought
ro Guan was like okay Darth Vader stares
at the end like it like they played it
pretty safe and so even though these are
like familiar characters
I'm hoping that the vibe will be
different somehow and we'll see
something outside of like what Star Wars
is it feel safe doing it could even be
to like I feel like this movie as like
we do want to land a movie I feel like
it's gonna be pretty land oh oh yeah and
they would like McDonald in that way
like I wouldn't be surprised if this
movie comes out like let's say it's a
huge success everyone's like talking
about Lando and then they're like okay
we're gonna do Atlanta movie as well
yeah they could do another you can do a
follow up with you they have so much
space in which to pound space there's so
much space in which to in which to play
with these characters and focusing on ha
and like you gotta remember that we're
still like in the early stages we're not
even done with like Disney's first Star
Wars yeah trilogy like a start up face
yeah this is only the second spin-off
and we have the rest of eternity for
Disney to release one Star Wars movie a
year like you know right now you're
gonna get up to - I don't you're gonna
do a man December like every year
eventually my thoughts they can do
anything like that it's at the it's at
the point where they're they're getting
the movies out of the way like this is
the one about the Death Star plans this
is the one about Han Solo they're gonna
run out of these obvious ideas at some
point so you know right let's do it why
not
we have that movie uh Solo Star Wars
story three and a half months away so
this is really the kickoff point of a
heck of a lot of marketing but uh thank
you for it yeah thank you for stopping
by watching the solo trailer thank you
for holding off on doing it you guys let
us know what you're most excited about
are you excited for the Han Solo movie
does this make you more excited let us
know in the comments and you can always
tweet us our twitter handles are right
here for you to tweet us right what did
Han Solo say in that scene with Emilia
Clarke someone please tell me yeah tell
me what he said I'm gonna listen to it
with headphones on I guess it's probably
closed captions on using this and the
Eagles won the Superbowl oh my god ah
thanks for watching